back here at home a brand new music
festival kicks off tonight in downtown
las vegas and it promises to be an
experience unlike any other but there
are some covid related requirements fans
need to show to get in orco mana joins
us live tonight at the downtown las
vegas event center with a look at the
event hey there orco
well sasha the lost and dreams music
festival features the sounds of dubstep
and dance music all with the visual
flair you can hear that pulsating music
here behind me the floor grounds here
just opened at 5 30 at the downtown las
vegas event center people have been
decked out in their best festival gear
flower crown sequences and yes some
masks as they continue making their way
inside now lawson dreams is being put on
by insomniac and this is the debut of
this brand new music festival organizers
say the three-stage event will deliver
an immersive experience like no other
also special about tonight's event are
the covid protocols in order to get in
fans must show proof that they've gotten
their first vaccine dose or a negative
covet test those we spoke to say they're
willing to do whatever it takes to enjoy
the festival
i think that it's really important that
we all like take these precautions and
necessary precautions
and
you know if everybody is on the same
boat then we can have event more events
like these in the future
organizers say the proof of vaccine and
negative kova test are ways to ensure
fan safety and again those fans are fine
with that if it means enjoying the
festival now lost in dreams just got
underway and it continues through 2 a.m
tomorrow morning reporting live downtown
orca mana 8 news now